طبعا اني اقف في منطقه الميدان اقف في
منطقه الميدان ويظهر خلفي في مسرح الهلال
هذا المسرح الذي اثاره غضب الناس بسبب ان
سقفه سقط والناس يعني يعدون ان هذا الخراب
بسبب الاهمال من قبل الجهات المعنيه
المسرح يرتبط به الناس روحيا في العراق
لانه شهد عام 1932
حضور كوكب الشرق ام كلثوم هنا والغناء على
خشبه هذا المسرح هذا المسرح بني عام 1918
في فتره الاحتلال البريطاني في العراق
ويبلغ من العمر 105 عام والناس طبعا
يناشدون الجهات المعنيه وهيئه التراث
والاثار في العراق باعاده اعمار هذا المسح
او الحفاظ على ما تبقى منه طبعا لاهميته
فهنا ايضا غنت السيده منيره المهديه رحمه
الله نعم احنا ايضا من صوتنا الى صوت
العراقيين
للحفاظ على هذه الا ثار لكن تعالي قولي لي
يعني 400 الف دولار بخمس دقائق من يسويها
بالعراق هذه
دليني الدرب والله وين اروح
انا اسويها بس شلون
[موسيقى]
تبيع من اجله يعني قطعه ارض او او سياره
اني عن نفسي مستحيل والله لاصير مو عادل
لو اصير عدعد ما تبيع بحتى
ما راح تتخلى عن قلم رصاص علشانك
شكرا يا زينب
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات